[Music]
it's just never what i want
wait hold on guys hold on we're supposed
to be playing i guess we're talking
about
real estate what's the budget it's a max
this is the worst thing to ask on the
air
before we now that we're recording our
social media
i want i may want to move and bianca
likes to look for places voluntarily for
her friends
and so i told her what i wanted and then
we
will hit him we'll we'll hit the button
we have no choice but to go hi hi hey
tell me tell me everything you look
really good thank you
tell me everything my little c boy my
little
uh oh yeah we'll talk about that um guys
i mean there's there's a lot of
quandaries here so all right so here's
what happened
did you do anything this week before i
launch into my
so that i don't i do it ten minute
monologue like let her speak
i'm telling a story you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're yelling at nobody
i'm yelling at three people okay um
will's got a burner where he says let
her speak
on on my twitter um
anything no just go god damn it okay so
you guys know i direct commercials right
so i don't
there's seagulls outside and they sound
like women screaming and every time it's
gonna make me laugh
because nothing's funny than women
screaming we'll get to
rich ramirez later now um
i so i i
i don't do beer i don't do alcohol
and but somehow my guy
seigle was like well i'll pay you more
to for a corona commercial
okay supposed to shoot in la then they
move it to dallas
for the talent and
i'm like i'm i
i don't really want to go to dallas not
because i'm against elsa i don't want to
know
because so i say i'll do it
you gotta fly me private just like i
don't wanna do it
if i'm gonna and uh how many instant
trees did you
so they do uh i haven't done that yet
i'm going to
thank you um look you're right to ask
you're absolutely right to ask um but
corona does so much for the community
it was worth it um fly private
and get there tuesday night
i got it i got tested monday negative
test tuesday uh
i think that was rapid negative
wednesday negative and we shoot
wednesday
12 hours inside everyone's wearing masks
and uh shields and there's
just like it's a pain but whatever and
then thursday morning
i get a phone call that i tested
positive
okay so now i'm in a hotel in dallas
and i've tested positive and i was like
[ __ ]
um i knew i shouldn't have come here
yeah blame pointing fingers why do you
make me do
all the [ __ ] that's childish the best
really the best parts of my personality
and so i'm stuck
in dallas so i take another test
that day the the positive i got thursday
morning i
actually took wednesday night then i
take a
test thursday morning get it back
after the positive thursday morning i
get it back thursday night and it's
negative
okay so now i'm one for one one and one
right i mean really i'm four and one but
whatever but no once
once you've gotten uh so i'm like all
right well let's take another one so i
take one
thursday night or no i'm sorry
anyhow i got i got i took it i took
another one friday
got another negative so at that point
legally you can
travel uh so i'm so i leave saturday
morning
and uh get back here
saturday and um
take a test yesterday negative again
some three negatives
uh and one positive uh which is kind of
the way my personality is anyway
and um i
but the question is fun
well the funny thing is when you think
you have it i took a four-hour
fever and i was like i have a fever i
didn't have a temper
i didn't have a thermometer i'm like i
have a fever i have to go to sleep sleep
for like three or four hours
and then get a thermometer and i'm like
i'm burning up
98.1 yeah the [ __ ]
like the sh i never thought i had a dry
cop i never had i
thought i had any of the symptoms and
when you look at it even my demographic
my age almost nobody dies
it's just all i'm like well i'm not
gonna die so then it was just a matter
of sitting in a hotel room that sucked
and it's 50 48 degrees in dallas and
overcast and just like
yeah ugh i'm not used to this i like the
sun guys
if it rains it stops then it goes back
to sunny
in l.a um now the question is
well you kept taking tests and you've
yeah the question i'm not
uh i'm not my my the moral aspect of it
isn't testing the moral aspect of it is
oh the one dumb thing i did was in
dallas
the in the restaurant at the hotel it
was like open
and there were like
it's a big restaurant there there were
very few people in it so i was like i
said to jesse the idea i was like let's
eat
some meanwhile i've never gone to a
restaurant in l.a i know in a year
i don't know it's just this you get
it's like uh suggestibility where you're
just like ah
i've just been on a plane with you for
four hours
i then i was in a in a at a work thing
and then i'm like we can sit in an open
restaurant and have the waiter come over
twice
seems fine um and
ultimately it was fine there was a point
where it wasn't fine because i had covid
then it turns out it didn't have it
everything i did was forgiveable
now what now the question is was it
forgivable are the state laws like
as a as a person in california you can't
do much
uh today we can now we can we'll get to
that in a second but um
you can't restaurants are close like
there's nothing you can do and i
haven't said that when they were open i
didn't eat outside i didn't do
any of this [ __ ] i ate outside once yeah
you went to the goodreads dad
yeah but you guys remember um
yeah so
was i wrong did i do
anything wrong is it
is really the question um
i don't know if that's the question what
do you think the question is the
question is
for me more your
it was a real-time experiment how it was
a real-time experiment of how accurate
the tests are because
we in la uh a lot of the like easy
access
tests were all done by curative well we
didn't talk about it but
an article came out about how curative
is just some
ranking dude that some 24 year old
that just started this company and they
got a 65 million dollar contract with la
and uh 60 of their tests are
bunk they're just false negatives all
like i just tell you your your
astrological sign
like this crystal what
um so apparently they were using
they just you know when someone comes
into like a load of discounts
yeah it's just like yo we got all these
discounts with someone there was a mask
kid who was doing that just like some
mask piece of [ __ ]
yeah so it's like now i'm
really confused on the accuracy of
the tests and i feel like
okay let's take up your guy all your
stats let's give them
12 tests how many things another one
other person
the produ the local producer the
commercial tested positive
okay then
had two negatives he was in the same
batch as me
i barely i dealt with him but not very
much
and he had a positive and then last i
heard two negatives so
it's like a are we relying like
are we i don't is the problem that all
of our [ __ ] on some
junk science tests like i don't know
what there's there's a lot of different
tests out there
used by different you're saying that
these are mood rings
it's what you're saying we're all taking
day to day because i
got tested after the curative thing i
started getting tested at kaiser
and they throw someone sits you down
they put it in your throat and then up
your nose and then they call you either
way
and that was the most thorough they do
your nose and your throat
but they do throw in the same swab same
swab but
they don't go the gross way
they do your throat and then they do
your nose they do throat then
one nostril then the other jesus and
someone does it and
these guys really want to know if you
have or not it's so weird they're so
nosy
so um then someone calls you no matter
what so someone called me the next day
and said you're negative and that was
the only time i felt like well that's a
whole other issue which is like
they weren't telling me they did call me
with the pot they do call you with a
positive which is pretty
yeah hey yeah it's very easy yeah hey
are you sitting down
um but i wonder how the
reliability of the tests we're taking
reliability of the rapids reliability of
like we don't know
where you're getting the test that i
don't look i understand that it's
not going to be foolproof in a 10 month
old
for sure no i do i don't it's
uh that's why you just take more it's
almost like you should
if you get a positive they should all be
free or some i don't know right
it was different companies so but it's
like yesterday i was supposed to get the
results between six and eight and i got
them at 10 30
at night like [ __ ] you guys um
so it's like the cable company yeah it's
worse than the cable company because
they don't tell you if you're gonna
we're gonna come and tell you if you're
gonna live or die
between six and eight um were you scared
uh no i mean you play out
the like i knew it
i knew it was gonna come to this did you
do the um detective
like the professor mustard in the
observatory like oh the hot witch hot
gust
did it to me like [ __ ] that hot
gus that i [ __ ] felt from that guy's
mouth
there was a point where i did apparently
i was on a zoom call
in a smallish office that the other guy
who got a positive had been in
yeah i was cursing the guy
uh he wasn't skinny like me i'll say
that
that came into my screaming uh
discrimination not a vegan um
discrimination i'll say that
um so uh
yeah but i didn't and then that once you
get a negative
but it's like you know eight hours or
ten hours of positivity
which was so negative yeah if negative
positive negative positivity
um so
yeah so i wonder if i was a full
nothing happened do you know what i mean
like i go i
was i a fool forever going to texas
and then i went to
palm beach for the gatorades i just made
everybody i just make everyone get super
tested
and that was fine
so i don't know what what's the dumb
thing and what's a fine thing to do
like i still don't know you will went to
hawaii
no one should yeah well i learned a lot
will took a non-necessary
vacation to our which you know yeah yes
maybe no didn't want to go to the beach
though made no money made no money
money's here well the money's at my
house we had to work
extra hard and will didn't even go to
the beach
no sorry that's actually
my favorite that's that's how we got
back in my good grades
like by not going to the beach oh he
didn't enjoy it you're like okay fine
well as long as you don't have fun
sick go wherever you want so i don't
i don't i i don't know i didn't learn
it's one of those things where like ah
that i learned nothing
that was a complete wash where
i thought and then what i didn't f i
made everyone get tested more than they
wanted to i just
was thorough about it it was a
make it was my good money and
so i don't [ __ ] know now the question
here's another ethical question
come on you know about these bash
backwash vaccines
bash backwash
so there's hospitals in l.a once you
open either pfizer
or the other one astrazeneca moderna
madonna
sorry once you open the package
they have eight hours to use them so
there's
a couple hospitals in la where
um you can line up because
people don't show up so yeah you can
line up
now there was an article the young la
vaccine chasers
but they take unofficial standby lines
in hopes of the shot
they can't get it yeah they can no they
can't why not you have to be
you can you can come but as soon as they
get there you have to be
in the tier that's open right now and
the only tier that's open is
um uh whatever worker was it called
exceptional worker what the hell is
incorrect
no no i it 100 because i thought i know
a guy who's
32 when got it and it's in none of the
categories
because when i read i read a thing about
i'm like oh [ __ ] we could just line up
and get it and they were saying that
they
it said that they're standing in line um
unnecessarily because they get turned
away if they don't qualify so maybe
there's some
you may be getting that confused with i
know i read it yesterday
so maybe it's just some unofficial [ __ ]
it's
if somebody over 65 is in the line they
jump the line
right no what i read was that
everybody's rushing
to these because they're gonna go bad so
get in line
and when they get up to it they
they basically all the extras go to
this i mean i could call the guy right
now who got it no this isn't about me
and you i'm just asking i'm just saying
that's what i read
he's but he i'm he's living proof that
that's not the system
right but i don't know if that is that
not the system or is that an unofficial
like [ __ ] it if you're there and it's
gonna go bad
you know what i mean well why would they
they're not gonna throw it away
no no the article literally said if you
don't
if you're not in the thing read this la
times article it doesn't say that
and uh that while they do not have
standby lines some people are given
doses that would otherwise be wasted
that's from the la
county department of health right but
who are the people
i mean i believe that you're friends no
no i if you if i don't want to read the
article on the line but
um i don't want to read it on the
podcast but there's an article in the la
times
um la times hell of a paywall you can't
even get really get one article
you can get covet articles but that's it
yeah you send me so much new york times
it's like you've had enough for them
i'm like [ __ ] i'm trying to send you a
message
um so that's crazy what
so then there's an ethical of course
there's a
these vaccines should be going to the
people that they're meant to go
no they're meant to go to 65 year olds
well they can't take work off
what do you want me to do about it i
mean what do you want me to do about it
as a it became a race thing like this
should be going to under
under serve okay i'm just a guy
so what should i do about it so now with
those people that like got in it's like
there's no more 65 or
anybody who qualifies and they're gonna
go bad so whoever's like
so what so now they have to get
the they don't have to do that for the
third or the second
shot do they uh the second shot i don't
know
so my guess is you don't have to wait in
the line again
yeah because it's like you need it or
else it's not you're
you're jonathan you're thinking i've got
a monkey on my back
for a vaccine um
so you know i don't i'm thinking about
this
i'm just thinking like standing in line
i don't like standing in line
for to get backstage at concerts
i don't i'll do anything for a [ __ ]
vaccine
i'll stand in line when i first saw that
i was like oh i'd do it and then i read
the article that was like oh they stand
in line for hours and get turned away so
i was like okay
no thanks but now the the guy who told
me got it and he said he
had 10 people get it on saturday and
none of them are old none of them are
early respond none of them are necessary
workers none of them
they're improv people yeah
no i mean like they're they love they
need a suggestion
of a place they need to they need a
place to work
and uh and a name and a funny job
um so am i wrong for maybe
thinking about getting this oh no now i
know isn't going what the hell
i i really was like about to and then my
hopes were dash when i researched it
yeah uh but maybe it depends on
hospitals maybe it depends on
that day not enough qualifiers came in
so [ __ ] it
yeah it it doesn't it's better to get
everybody back yeah that's what i'm
saying it's like i'm doing my civic dude
i thought
i'm doing this yes but you need to get
other unders it's like [ __ ] i
i have to do that so i have to make sure
everyone
in the demographics gets it and then i
go like oh
i shall now i shall get my that's not
last i'm not
uh bribing [ __ ] since there's an
article about that today too
no no they were only bribed the bribes
are only 10 grand which is like
come on guys 10 grand ain't going to
[ __ ] yeah ain't going to get
back that that ain't gonna you got this
10 grand
well that's what i'm saying you should
bribe someone in line i i thought about
having a line holder
that's a bridge too far for me i will be
the line holder
but i don't want to walk up and be like
hey babe how's it going uh this is my
boyfriend everyone
and then people and then someone gets
shot someone's gonna get shot
oh yeah because someone's like yo i have
i don't i live with my grandma
and my baby like i'm yeah
no i don't know what if you tipped
everyone in the line behind you yeah i
don't
think the people that were brought
doctors were being bribed
is the was the story but it was in
beverly hills
10 grand which is like guys guys
opening's got to be a hundred
[Music]
if you know anything about vaccine
bribes i'm a vaccine fixer
sending t take notaro they should just
send her in
um the uh yeah there's no you
open with a hundred grand yeah that's
minimum make it worth their [ __ ]
while
right 10 grand don't waste my time
don't i don't leave i don't get out of
bed for less than a hund
and then newsome now is opening
they say he's opening but he's basically
just sent leaving it up to the counties
uh he just went back to tear yeah we
went back to the system but it's not
gonna
everyone's in purple outdoor dining
um and salons
the funniest and like anything you could
do outdoor right
uh i guess i don't even know this is
when he goes through it and it's like
card rooms after like car yeah yeah when
they get very specific yeah
card room okay what do you why the why
them
um yeah there are weird there's like
massage
places there's haircut places that
by the way i gotta think that haircut
places are gonna be
significantly worse off after this
barber shops is there nothing because
everyone's because everyone realizes
like
if you can figure this out i don't know
girl's hair is not good
yeah i don't mean girls girls aren't
impossible no everybody knows girls are
impossible
uh beauty stuff there's i don't think
that be i think beauty is
only going to grow right i think with
women forever people are pissed
like it's like growth my friends who
have gray hair that get it colored
on a timely basis are struggling
they're like you know going to the pond
putting mud in their [ __ ] hair what
are they doing
just the actually but it's like i don't
it's like
feels a little like i gotta do this
again yeah this is not what i'm
saying yeah that's not the lifestyle i'm
accustomed to but you
you just do a tee critique yeah snippy
snip
and then i abused my power on the
commercial
and had the hair laid i'm there
wow i mean i didn't i didn't first of
all i didn't need to i just there was
nothing to do i was like hey
hey lunch cut my hair and then
anyhow was it while she was eating
anyhow i gave her got it
get well soon honey you were great
um so but it begs the question which is
so uh newsom cannot win because
he was getting hammered by people on the
right and then he opens and then
hammered by people well now everybody
so they closed because we were at a
certain capacity and we were worse
and we're opening we're worse now uh
from what i read
i see i think he just was like
i don't know okay yeah i think he was
like well i what i
the only thing in his defense is that
the christmas surge wasn't as bad as
they thought
it was going to be so i read a article
and there's a model and it's i think
it's only for california
but um
yeah not a good time to lift yeah
but okay so the model has been correct
so far
it just hasn't been accurate on the
amount but it's
predicted roughly how everything is
going to go
since the summer and it said i read this
a few weeks ago and it said that this
surge
is gonna be
bad until the last week of january in
the first week of
february and then it's going to come
down after that
and then it said if 70
of us like in these big cities get the
vaccine
by the summer then in the rest of the
summer there's going to be
very little covet in la but it can't
figure out what it's going to be like in
in fall so i don't know the amount of
vaccines there are
is not good they're well if you look at
the world we're not
bad percentage-wise we're not good but
the amount we're giving out actual more
vaccines than anywhere else we have more
and we're giving out more the problem is
that we um
there is not the amount in the
stockpiles that we thought
so it's really hard to make a plan
and get these models based on numbers
based on how many vaccines we have and
then there's like i've read an article
that
because during trump
fights are kept saying change the
wording on
the contract they have with them and the
wording basically
says if you we won't accept any extra
doses pfizer has to pay for extra doses
they give but fights or doses are in
a pack of six and our wording is we'll
only take
five and fights are just kept saying
like you have to change it
we can't send you five or something like
that well
so now we're getting less doses it's
this
it's the reason there's an extra dose in
the pfizer
right so it's it's statistic it's like a
statistical issue i believe
um but i just mean it's so
it's really hard to
the um the us's we're up to a million a
day which is good
million day rolling average which is uh
and while
not a miracle it's
more than anywhere else apparently if
the
if the variants get too strong modern is
working on a
booster yeah a booster shot great thank
you moderna
um yeah so i [ __ ]
god bless i hope the model is right
i don't i'm sure it's right there's no
yeah there's you know
but the the good news is that
if ever there's we have enough vacs for
everybody by the end of the year
now the fact that you want it to be
we have enough facts for everybody by
may
and we don't is a nightmare and also
like my mom's 87
in pennsylvania she hasn't gotten
approved yet which is like
guys what
what do you need or what does she need
to do and you know what
she needs to do she needs to be [ __ ]
fat or in jail
which is a whole other issue that people
with diabetes are getting it before
healthy people there are people with
comorbidities getting it before healthy
people which
is known in the business as a perverse
incentive
just learned it gonna drop it a lot
um uh it's a nightmare
and
i wouldn't want to be in charge of this
that's what that's all i think about i'm
like you know what
it sounds extremely complicated there's
so many moving parts
they [ __ ] so they the reason
um trump didn't enact the defense
production bill is because that was
basically socialism
yeah basically uh
which uh next time someone brings up
what's wrong with socialism
remind them socialism won world war ii
anyhow you were saying tell me more bad
about it
about this awful yeah but that's just
okay
so sometimes we can use it but it's up
to you okay cool
um so this isn't bad enough 400 000
people a year no
didn't didn't cross the rubric
um so uh
so now they're going to enact the
defense production act
also if you've i got a i got a lot to
say about this but
tell me come on neil the news
if you watch first of all watching the
news now
it is so boring
without d without the ratings machine
djt
come on i like it no it's better for the
country
but it is a worse tv show i likened it
to when
they fired charlie sheen from two and a
half men
it's so bad was it the right thing to do
yeah
was it a worse show because of it wait
who took over
ashton kutcher oh yeah it sure was a
worse show with ashton kutcher
and i like ashton kutcher i like
john cryer i thought the lady did a good
job
i thought the kid did a good job the
half ma
of the half man did a good job um
but man there's something about that
charlie sheen
something about that [ __ ] just hits
it he charlie sheen could hit it
just right wait where because i used to
watch spin city
i loved spencer yeah he he took over he
took over
and it was still it was so good it was a
different and usually i don't like a
takeover charlie sheen
is a very good comedy actor yeah he's
like a very
i don't think he's funny he's not a
funny person he can't generate his own
material
but uh i never saw hot shots but i
remember people liking them
hunches for two yeah he's very good in
uh in
in uh in major league charlie shane
charlie shane's a good comedy actor
he great i would he's a great sitcom
actor because with charlie sheen it felt
like what the
is this guy doing tv for we're really
getting something here right
um so with all due respect
to john cryer
ashton kutcher the lady the half man
well the set um
it was not just it was a worse tv show
without a maniac in the center of it
and uh that's who donald trump was for
the news
he was a maniac at the center office
and he understood it and he played to it
and i mean him they're like the same
they're really similar i feel like you
if you looked up
try if you googled charlie sheen and
donald trump i'm sure there's
10 pictures of them together will um if
only yeah but this does this guarantees
nothing he's going to hit like maps
are they ever not a lot of split screens
a lot of split seas
no they were never together oh yeah no
interesting and you would have thought
oh
they were together yeah no so john cryer
between you and me looks like me bald a
little middle eastern you paul
yep yep so anyhow um
i rest in power king djt
you made the news way worse the news is
about like the senate and like
committees and and and secretary
assignments and just like donald trump
made the news
like a he made the news yeah yeah really
he made the news a card a cartoon and
his news was in
every other type of news whether it was
my like reality show blurbs
sports any kind of he overpowered the
news
he got and ran into every other
every other segment a i've always said
an amazing entertainer
i loved it an amazing entertainment i
was i loved the apprentice
no the apprentice remember beat every
it was number one he beat every actor
every writer ev [ __ ] everybody
as himself so i i've never said he's not
a great entertainer
an amoral disgusting piece of [ __ ] yeah
terrible
um but but made the news
um the entertainment section apparently
that
uh when he when he was building
mar-a-lago
um the neighbors complained because you
know when you pay that much for
your property you have a lot of saying
power
and they may he signed into
he signed a thing saying this will never
be his permanent
now now they're residency now they're
like get out what are you doing here
yeah it's like i forgot something it is
weird to like
live at live at your country
live is it a country club is a hotel
it's a country club it does it's not
like
they don't it's a country club but it
has a res
it's a country club like tennis golf and
then i guess it has a residence
which is creepy it's in west palm have
you ever been to west palm beach what's
the vibe
well i was that's i shot the gator
gatorade there uh it's just very
republican
really so it's just very it's like it's
republican like jeffrey epstein had a
house there there's like a small island
where like the west palm beach like the
that there's like a strip
it's probably a mile or two and it's i
think like eight blocks wide
oh so it's small the rich part like the
pump like when they talk about if
someone says i'm from palm beach
nope sorry uh that's not the real thing
that's uh
that's like mark that's marked by mark
jacobs if you know what i mean
that's funny it's like the office yeah
it's like
target um the uh
so yeah so that's pump but it's just cr
it's just white like
dorks just white dorks just bad
bodies and like guys with huge upper
bodies and tiny legs
um uh i caddied i know these people well
i know
did you get yeah in philly in philly in
chicago
six years what lugging bags for [ __ ]
i cannot see you
like being happy yeah it can't
uh it was it never really
the funny thing was they didn't
it was great because we would play cards
between the loops oh uh the caddies
before we started bit like we'd be in
the thing and playing cards
it was just it was like a bunch of old
dudes like when the factory closed there
was just like it's so like new
desperate yeah it was a very disparate
types of people there was a guy named
richard who was homeless
who slept in the trees i mean just crazy
[ __ ]
crazy um and then there was like
six of us that were in high school oh
that's cute but i would smoke and
it was great that was cool play cards
and smoke um
you were always an old man always from
the very beginning
um seriously
now moving on so what
so what a football we had a big football
game
and trey songz got a cop and a headlock
um it's really funny for tray seconds he
had him
he had him in a headlock and
now and what's funny is they're like the
fans are telling the cops that
it's like the fans are going to side
with [ __ ] a celebrity
they didn't [ __ ] meaningless teenage
girls are on
trace you're kidding um
but you see why the cop came and i'm
like now i'm on the cop side
what do you what happened wouldn't put a
mask on really trey songz wouldn't put a
mask out that isn't why
i apparently it is why i i can't
that's as the story on tmz they said
it's the cops he wouldn't put a mask on
security ass you wouldn't put a mask on
what a dick cops came yeah now i'm like
this is the whiplash of this era where
you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] the cops no [ __ ] trey songz
yeah well that's kind of that's not i
mean
everyone is more for putting on a mask
than any of it
but i mean the people who are saying
[ __ ] the cops yeah
are also part of the talking points is
take coven seriously
yeah but i also think they black men are
i don't think he's targeted etc but i
feel like the mask story
is just you know [ __ ] comes out later
and it's like
yeah of course god damn it i was on your
side
of course uh but maybe
we'll see we'll see we'll see it's been
a while since race on
giraffe i don't even know what songs he
has
uh he has oh god uh
show me the list and i'll sing you them
what i can't even read them no no
you know no no slow motion neighbors
know my name
bottoms up nobody else but you bottoms
up
can't help but wait i just made these
titles up no bottom's up
no they don't sound like fake no bottoms
up
uh uh i don't like okay well
you know why don't want to hear about
guys [ __ ]
don't care none of my business stop
talking about it when you watch porno
what do you do there's a guy
naked there and you're so against naked
guys well i have a different observation
oh that
well the funny i mean a lot of guys just
watch
menage women or whatever oh so there's
more
uh yeah you guys are in porn are like
the activating ingredient
otherwise it's just like yeah basically
like otherwise it's just a
lady dance like then i gotta i don't
know
it helps um so
i'd rather see her
suck a human penis than a dildo for
instance
okay now you want to talk about gay
gayness this is where gayness creeps in
though if you're ever talking to a
straight guy
ask him does he like watching [ __ ] shots
and there's montages of gum shots and
when he says yeah i go like
you ever think about why you like
watching gum shots i should go
and then you leave because he's going to
want to fight you when he realizes that
waiting for gum shots is a wildly
homoerotic thing to do
if not downright gay well yes to
speaking of the active ingredient
speaking of life it's i just like it
from the storytelling you know how
oh yeah narrative i need to know is that
what parasite was missing yeah
well yes parasite except that
yeah the wrong person came is the
if you're if you're saying that the peep
yes
again nonsense and the great thing about
parasite no one's brought it up ever
in popular culture since the day it won
the oscar because it's not
that potent a movie very well made good
filmmaking etc etc
but of course
suck my dildo okay um
so treyson's uh rust in power team
and also dave chappelle resting power
king for getting covered we had don't
they rest in power
i'm kidding he's resting um
and power king um i thought we were
gonna
have to get we're gonna co-cask it
because we both got positive on the same
day well hopefully this is a false one
too
i don't think his is false he [ __ ]
does a lot of [ __ ] outs
he does a lot a lot of interacting
like he's not a guy that i guess he gets
a lot of people tested but
that was a numbers game um yeah when i
went to his show in new york was a nurse
there it's like kate time to test
so what do you mean everybody or just
him any single person that went
to a show yeah had to be tested by the
nurse yeah
but he's just getting it but he's doing
he's it's he's dealing with
thousands of people numbers games it's
just a number it was just gonna get him
eventually not like me
neil um
shout out to alexander navalny
truly not giving a [ __ ] if we know who
alexander navalny is in russia
he was a putin critic who they uh
tried to poison which i was going to
tweet it wasn't worth it but if you
think trump doesn't want to poison
people
you're out of your mind um
and then he made of he made a youtube
navalny made a video the problem is it's
too [ __ ] long
it's like two hours yeah which is even
mind you it has
89 million views uh
i think it's probably up to higher than
that because 82
yesterday morning no i checked today
correct um
show me that's not the one you're not
going to believe this guys it will
look popped in the wrong video it's not
it's a it's a youtube well
yeah but it's not the protest yeah don't
worry about it it's it's a
we fell for it it's in russia it's not
you can't
it's in russian you're never gonna um
uh but that guy
maybe a week to live navalny
yeah well you know what he brought to
russia well okay he went to russia
and then wasn't locked up at the airport
yeah as soon as he said so everything on
the airplane he was watching rick and
morty someone take a picture of it
really yeah
that i love him even more yeah so
apparently those people who poisoned him
were following him for three years we're
tracking this guy for three years
following him like the the insurance
goons that see if your back is really
hurt
following him for three years and then
the
kremlin responded saying yeah well he's
just following him
there's no laws against people uh
but it's funny the level of
putin's really corrupt russia's rea
every you want to talk about like the
saint lunatics
he is surrounded by the saint lu he's
nellie
and everybody who's murphy lee anyone
he's ever been cool with
has like is a billionaire now yeah like
[ __ ] ever you're either a billionaire
or you're dead
that's it's flip a coin uh
but it's really the level of corruption
is i watched half an hour of that video
and
it was crazy i did you make it to the
house did you make it to the house
no the he's building a palace no so
basically one of the reasons why they're
protesting
is because um of the fact that
navalny got you know like detained
immediately but because
apparently putin has received the
biggest bribe in history which is
like 1.8 billion dollars and then he
made
he built he used that money to build a
palace
on the black sea and it's so
insane this house is so insane and so
now everybody's
very mad and that's so apparently the
remarkable thing about the protests
is that there's only 40 000 people which
have isn't the biggest protest in russia
but it was in like
50 it was 50 degrees below zero and 50
countries oh no no and no but there was
it was there was one where it was 50
below and the people still showed up for
but i just mean it was so widespread
white people because it's up there
russia black
aren't there and they wouldn't have
shown up okay
so it was just wide wider spread than
any other protest
in 50 cities so i think at 50 below
so now he's going to have to feel
non-guilt for 10 seconds
instead of the five that he normally i
mean i yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ]
no and there's i don't know how they're
gonna
he's so corrupt like corruption means it
just soaked into everywhere
it's so soaked in how do you challenge
a system that's [ __ ] mm-hmm it's like
who
okay everyone's protesting okay so you
got to take down everything
yeah they it's corrupt that's what i
during the when the trump and the the
the
capital and the voting irregularities
and all that [ __ ]
i don't think because americans are you
know
a historical and don't know anything
about any place
but america or what they're told about
america is
you know when when other governments are
corrupt they don't say we're corrupt
they say [ __ ] like they were voting
irregularities
they just they do it under the guise of
the law but it's they just lie about the
law
they lie they just lie and they go like
no this is
this is good for you this is the
constitution
and it's not and putin's a prime example
of where he's
there was i there was a part where he
was super against like yeltsin in the
90s
meanwhile he was that's when he got on
it's just like yeah it's it's all kind
of the same
thing um you have iran threat and i
don't know what that means
so the like supreme leader they tweeted
it out
this is america's number one iranian
news podcast i think it is it's
pronounced
iran right cool
so um they tweeted out that twitter took
it down because they're like oh
that that's fake that wasn't from like
iranian officials but basically it's a
photo
of trump on a golf course with pull it
up trump
iran iran threat trump golf course
anyways it basically says it's from the
iranian government
and um you can read that uh no i can't
read that
uh i could read it really slowly and not
you can't see all of it right
here but basically there's a um shadow
there's a shadow of like a stealth
bomber yeah over him
it's not the whole image anyways and
it's basically saying
just because you're out of the office
doesn't mean
you can't get got like yeah it was it
was basically saying like
i don't know why you're not pulling it
up as good but basically it says
um it says something really ominous
like it's you can see there's a shadow
yeah no but it says like from the actual
tweet it says something like
revenge's yeah it's the most like
it actually says revenge is like yeah
[Music]
and it just it's like you know it may be
boring on our news but
in trump world it's still a [ __ ]
movie revenge
that's that's the old uh americans have
the watches we have the time [ __ ]
right it's just like pooh over that dude
whose name i don't remember
so maybe yeah yeah but they're like this
is like we're gonna
all this says is you we're gonna avenge
everybody who had to do with solemnity's
death that's a tough one i don't and
and i'm american and i don't know who to
root for so then now the gp's like oh
biden should be on this
he's threatening a former president this
is not okay
from khamenei's actual twitter account
it was but they took it down saying it
was fake like somebody hacked it then
now it's on his website like the
ministry of that's funny it's on his
personal website so it's like
no no no this youtube channel
it's fun um yeah it's fun it's fun
in five minutes out there it's like how
halloween is
you're god bless you um yeah so
well i mean yeah
ah don't write checks you can't cash
yeah i mean that's where you hear that
presidents get two one or two secret
service agency like
you guys sure that's enough two
two two i mean it's not
and they're usually the ones that are
retired or gonna retire
like it's an easy are you sure or you're
basing that on no because i heard you
fellow americans with jack lemmon no i'm
not what
uh jack lemmon and walter matthau made a
buddy picture
no i didn't tell americans about two
retired presidents on a road trip
i believe i've only let's go to a clip i
i don't i heard that it's such an easy
like carter you know just just hang out
and
watch watch a guy hammer nails into wood
a peanut farmer whatever he has that's
really funny
uh oh the movie neil oh mommy that's did
i go to the premieres in my
wheelhouse what year orbit two
96. no i mean you want to talk about
norbert
i was up for directing or that's how
[ __ ] old i am
i had meetings on orbit are you serious
it's dead serious
that's really funny um okay wait the
inauguration did you watch it i didn't
watch it i didn't watch a goddamn frame
of it
it it you know what was really funny
was it was a laughable amount of
celebrities
it was just so many celebrities i don't
i don't remember i don't remem i i
always just think of the swearing in
i don't remember any because they
don't because it's all inside right this
is the only time it's been like
on display because a lot of the um
a lot of it was pre-recorded so
everybody can watch usually it's
like a ball or like a gala or something
[ __ ] that you're not
really winning circle [ __ ] no it's not
foreign
uh i saw that john legend sang
uh nice and chrissy blew it apparently
she tweeted about it the night before
what happened like how much she like
just
played record she just recorded john
doing sound check
and like but no one knew he was supposed
to do it so it was like oh i wasn't
supposed to do that
chrissy who's sober now apparently and
i'm very happy about it yay
um because uh yeah you know i don't like
alcohol except when it comes to
commercials
um but yeah i just thought the funniest
thing is how
biden's that vitamins bernie
went so viral from yeah he was people
talked about him more than they like
i'm happy to not care about the news
anymore i don't want to hear i don't
want to hear it
i just you know what this feels like
this feels like when
i used to i felt obliged somehow when
blake played for
the clippers to watch the games somehow
just like i don't know if they're on i
wanted it was like a good
procrastination
and then once he moved to detroit i had
like an extra
five hours a week and that's how i feel
now where i'm like i don't have to watch
the news at all like no
i haven't turned it no it's just back to
[ __ ] granular nerd [ __ ] which i
but even if you go well before trump it
was normal before trump a black guy was
present it was crazy it's
been crazy for 12 years yeah a black
president do you
imagine um making regular laws
uh yeah and before that it was bush so
then it was then it was more
uh the nine eleven it was we were in
wars yeah
watching t watching the news during bush
was
extremely complicated for me there was
so many
yeah i was younger but like in school we
had to watch it and be like okay report
what do you guys
bring in a an article but there was so
much going on that was very confusing
weapons of mass attraction they haven't
found any saddam
it just it was overwhelming yeah 911
afghanistan there's a year right there
yeah danny
rock started that's a 102 and then iraq
started in 03.
right and then they were all islamabad
i don't know it was really yeah uh
so news is obama was
he wasn't he was no charlie sheen i'll
say that
um he was charlie sheen on spin
city um and what else uh
[ __ ] you want to talk about rest in
power king literally literally literally
a king
gone too soon no one cares about me
will became prepared with some new drops
was a bad dude he's stupid um
we'll be using that more i'm sure is
that actual biden or that's
yes cornpop was a bad dude
um i didn't watch his speech how was it
he was actually
fine yeah not a lot of he doesn't
here's the thing about biden if he's out
i
old people don't do good in cold weather
he was good
okay no one's good in cold weather it's
like
he's better when he's young when he's
like
he's better than humidity sunglasses
that's what i would say if you're going
to put them outside put them in the rose
garden and then
starting in april get him outside
because then he's vital
but you know when people are cold it's
just you're like
60 of yourself yeah even even if you're
when it's
a snow person um who i like but
i like snow people more than water
people but i i'm not crazy about either
them really
snow people snow people are a lot of
times they are water people
hmm like yeah they like i surf and then
i
board like i live in the beach i live in
there really
and then i go to people heavenly
would you rather be in the snow or in
the beach i'd rather be well this is a
tough one
in the beach i'd rather be
snowboarding than at the beach
liar it's not it's true i like
snowboarding you snowboard yeah i'm
pretty good at it
really thanks for joining us okay uh
yeah i just something it i i
you don't like outdoor stuff i don't but
what i do is i'll put
what's going on hot hot the hot pocket
the [ __ ] yeah theater things
two and a half salon paws two in each
shoes
i mean i just load up with heaters
and uh it's not good for the environment
but it's good for this is my nardole
it's great down hilio
so larry king uh gone too soon
uh and uh i made fun of him a couple
weeks ago now i won't cause he's dead
and um he was a
he was a we don't need to appraise him
no he's done it yeah he's done it for
himself
he did larry king um bygone era
like did you ever watch you're too young
but toward the end
of the tonight show there was like
no with johnny no no no there would be
art you could watch arsenio
um which yeah that's naturally supposed
to do
but then carson was in his last year and
he'd have like jimmy stewart on
and it was like i'm not gonna be able to
see this no he wasn't like was it bad
no it was cool because it it it was from
[Music]
the 50s it was just guys that from a
bygone
era larry king's like that where it's
like
a it the way the
country was simpler and the media was
simpler and you could just be at
eight o'clock on cnn and go like where
are you from
right just be an inane interviewer now
you can't do that
um and it's more oppositional etcetera
etcetera but
but it was yeah he's from a bike on air
and tom brokaw
retired also um this week so we didn't
look we don't have it on the street
thought he was already retiring no i
know it's like he was an ombudsman it's
like dog
no one no one knew no one was like where
is brokaw in
no one knew uh you have army hammer part
du
yo it's weird what happened what do you
do
apparently an ex came out saying that
harmy hammer was like urging her to get
surgery to remove two of her ribs so he
could barbecue them and eat them
damn like stars are just like us
and she's like he was absolutely not
joking about that because he came out
in a dress and it was like no we were
just ah come on guys
it's rib rib play barbecue and eat her
ribs
rib blade and i'm sure she dated him for
another
eight years i know that's the problem
that's again it's like
yeah and you stayed with them you
[ __ ] shallow [ __ ]
all of them you asked me for a
kidney or i'm gonna eat your heart it's
like you [ __ ] off dude
that's weird yeah and all the women that
were
into him too i'm assuming we're hot and
could have just
[ __ ] another hot guy yeah but i think
he was a little special yeah
um but yeah so
what's up with this guy i mean have you
ever had any
that kind of fantasy [ __ ] where
someone's like
uh no i've never no one's ever asked me
to do anything that i wasn't willing to
do
because they never i it's not like i'm
not willing to do stuff
i just what if you knew it was really
creepy but it was complete just dirty
talk
but it was made you uncomfortable um
if it's if i know it's dirty talk if
they've signed something that lets me
know it's dirty talk
they sign my dirty talk waiver um
uh then i then i don't care then say
whatever you want
then it's like say [ __ ] whatever you
want but if she starts dropping hints
like i'd love
you to just ugh like eat my ribs and
be like your face is super
even i'll say a girl wanted me to
she kind of wanted me to [ __ ] other
people in front of that kind of thing
and i was kind of like
this is not coming from a great place
just fyi like you wouldn't want this
normally if
some trouble have a look i'll do it
don't get me wrong but i'm not going to
like it
i'm going to only be 80 erect to my
normal
83 percent hi
um what is the kimono well that's just
the joke i made which is
q anon is um basically
astrology but they get [ __ ] done
um and um oh this is a
bigger question than than um
this is about laurie steve harvey's kid
she's so pretty i love her so much she's
pretty do we know anything about her
no she's a rich kid here's the
the quandary okay
if you're and we should ask chris about
this although he's not gonna give us
he's not he can't speak honestly about
it um
lori harvey's with michael b jordan and
uh
it's fantastic and people love it she's
she's gone
she's she's talking taking all the
greats down
she really is she's burnt through yeah
as a future
yeah she's just [ __ ] like every diddy
every
time daddy interesting which is all the
top uh
black men trey songz of course you know
what's weird about diddy
that she dated his son yeah
and he's also very good and then did he
and then
takes diddy on vacation with
steve harvey and the wife which is so
weird
but i choose a landscaper mansion
um yeah well that's one of those things
where it's like
that's i don't know like whatever is
that you can do it all the time
of course they do um but we are not moms
we're not potential
moms so it's different uh
is it worth
i just sometimes i wonder if steve
harvey ever thinks like
man i would have been better off raising
this girl in dallas
like man i would have been better off if
15 if i just raised it again not like he
can do it i'm just saying no
if you're steve harvey you're born like
middle class i don't know how he's born
but he was just like a
real regular guy like even the first
part of his comedy career he was
yeah uh he was a high teller right but
before that
he was he lived in dallas he owned a
comedy club
like he owned a community yeah eric
about it was a waitress apparently
though
yeah um erica voodoo has also been a
comedy club waitress
yes that's steve harvey's um um laugh
shack
yes or i don't remember what it was
called and i remember he i would hear
stories of like
man steve harvey [ __ ] mcs and
good it is hard to follow really if
you're the headliner
if you're but he's black emcee so it's
they do a half an hour between everybody
oh yeah
[Music]
so but you wonder if
you'd be better off steve harvey's
comedy house
um if you'd be better off because
just be i don't just like a normal life
instead of
but maybe it's impossible if you're
raising daughters now who are good
looking for them not to be
instagram would she be better off dating
hot [ __ ] [ __ ] in dallas
or the hot [ __ ] [ __ ] in l.a i
think they live in atlanta
or what okay fine i just mean like what
do you mean what's the city i
uh i get or i guess it's just she's that
she's
young right yeah she's just in popular
culture
in yeah and
and you just wonder like ah i don't i
it's a parent it's a thing i can't speak
to because i don't know what it's like
to have kids but
but you mean just shield them from
popularity yeah
somehow like i don't think chris's
daughters are gonna end up
like her but i i also don't know
it's just access to being
access to like let's say this wasn't
social media let's say this is 1985. i
don't think anybody would know
lori harvey that's what i'm saying you
know but i
have been better off right but well i
think it's inevitable
regardless of if you're famous or not to
like kids now they want to look really
sexy on the internet
no everyone kids always want to look
really sexy now you can be on the
internet and gain likes and gain
attention blah blah
so if you're already famous you have an
already famous
like step up she strikes me as like
pretty good looking she's really she's
like that's not a great photo of her
okay
put go to images
she's hot she's like generally
very yeah she's just like pretty good i
don't know she's like
i don't think she's hotter than most
girls in her category do you know what i
mean yeah but
she's let's just be honest though just
because you
are famous and have a kid doesn't mean
they're always hot so i think the odds
of course i mean there's many examples
that i'm not gonna mention
no and there's some where i feel like
they say they're hotter they take after
her daddy
a lot of the time some say they're
hotter than they are
because they're famous there's a one i'm
thinking of right now and i've seen them
like
they aight yeah no there's there's there
it's a it's 60 40 that they're hot
but sometimes they just look take after
they daddy
um so my question is come on now
i i don't this isn't like i don't think
steve's put her in harm's way i don't
any of that [ __ ]
yeah i guess i just wonder
i wouldn't wish this for chris's
daughter or dave's or like guys i'm
friends with daughter but i think she
wants it i don't think you get to get
like
her status without wanting it
okay so you think even if she wants it
you don't think it's good for her
no i don't think it's good for her but i
also don't
it seems like she's just a
pre-basketball wife
you know like pre-loving hip-hop so you
mean because she's just famous because
social and dating people it just seems
like
ah there's that's fool's gold
you know what it seems like to me
remember when you were um
doing a commercial somewhere i don't
know maybe nike and spain you said it
you're trying not to be like you know
big time everybody and be cool and low
maintenance but
i think you told me like it took me a
day and a half not to want everything
serena williams got like the same
treatment that's funny
so uh it reminds me of that it's like
everyone else my age even without
celebrity attached to them is doing this
[ __ ] yeah i want to do it
i got a famous dad like yeah all the
other famous
kids kids are doing it yeah am i gonna
be the honorable one and not do it
yeah i guess i guess uh
the simmons kids did it joey simmons all
of them
um all the kids do it yeah even like
when
uh willow smith came out with i whipped
my hair
then all these other famous kids were
like i want to sing but you know the
story about that
she did it and then was like i don't
like this
yeah and then and will was pushing her
like no you do like this and then she
cut literally cut her hair and will was
like oh wait okay can't sing that song
oh well you know the thing is though
steve harvey has a book
called think like a man that's for women
so i feel like she kind of is
the one steve thinks of it that that's i
guess that's my only question and she's
an adult
etc like all the [ __ ] but i wonder
i think i'm more than anything talking
about what
like the nightmare of being a parent is
in the age of social media
yeah just and then they get access to
fame
you can cut it off by the way i feel
like you have to do this
a little just i'm not really gonna look
at what my daughter's doing right
would you if you had a daughter let's
just say accidentally
and she brought home a boyfriend would
that
creep you out well i mean that's just
one of the things you just gotta
that's one of the things
um
don't let him take it out on you um
uh the i don't i that
is f like that's unavoidable like yeah
you're gonna come to a sexual age and
then you just have to
it's like an impossible crucible and the
only good news is they're as
uncomfortable with it as you
like everyone's uncomfortable right
i guess it's the age of social media
and if she has a hunger
for it and but steve didn't put like
even the simmons kids were on the
reality show
so i i don't i don't even know what i'm
asking
other than like is this good right
because i don't i
like i said i wouldn't wish this
if chris's daughter's like burned
through half i wouldn't be
like i wouldn't know how to talk to him
about it i wouldn't if dave's daughter
is
super young now but like if she became a
thing i don't think dave would be like
geeked off this [ __ ] yeah what i mean
sure but i also don't know what he could
do i don't know what you can do
yeah what can you do become a sex symbol
you
but at the same time she's 24. so um
i guess you just send her to voicemail
what else can you do um
that we kind of covered this but about
the cops it's the whiplash of like
they there there was an article in l.a
times about
uh or no it wasn't in l.a times because
i've been able to read it
about uh how bad santa monica
pd [ __ ] up when they were like looting
and all that stuff
and there was a i was reading the
article so there's
about total on staff 220
give or take cops available
santa monica pd oh in san joaque and at
night
they have about eight cops on duty just
most nights
there's only eight cops patrolling santa
monica it's kind of like
guys are we gonna have to do a heist it
just seems like that doesn't
i don't know how many you should have it
seems like that's probably
20 should i again of course people don't
commit crimes
as much as you think of course i yeah
but it seems like
eight how many if i was having a party
i might have two you know i mean i would
get some
if i had a lit i don't [ __ ] know like
i eight doesn't seem like enough for
i don't even know how big santa monica
is so again i don't know what i'm
talking about it's
right there you don't know i know i can
see it but i don't
i've never asked it any questions about
how big it is
um so when when 91 000 people i don't
know
eight it's eight square miles and it's
91 000 people
so eight people for eight miles though
that makes eight seconds
like i'll handle this mile yeah it's a
little
i'd my heart would race if they're like
you got this mile i mean one what do you
[ __ ]
mile the world i was another guy
you think the world is like 1970s new
york
it's not there's no rubble no
i told you i was listening to glenn beck
and his his
first ad was for tasers which [ __ ]
made me laugh so
hard like tasers tasers
you you bought you have a taser of
course but i bought it as a
as a goof because i saw the tasers i was
like oh i'm gonna oh
i was on a conference call i'm like i'm
getting a taser if you guys will excuse
me so funny
um because i just never seen a taser
store what else what are his ads
that was the only one i heard was tasers
yeah but then somebody else was
listening like
um ben shapiro his are all like
tasers it's all just like defense
yeah they're just fearful um
but then the day of the looting they had
40 people
40 cops on duty and most of them were at
with the with the blm crew
who were on the at the ocean they were
on ocean
drive beeps revenue sure
uh and then they they ended up [ __ ]
but then looters were just
willy-nilly and people were calling
9-1-1 and they were like you're on your
own they were literally saying you're on
your own
um so it's funny the
it's more whiplash of how
like they i don't think they would have
stopped the losers even with 40 cops
but they knew the looters knew that they
would get away with it and blm would be
blamed
because they're there and people still
think it's blm people
it's like there was padding the buddy i
talked to i was like so black
so you know all the black you black
people love
camping they're known for it that's why
they got
rei and patagonia and because
they're a deep abiding love of the
[ __ ] camping
um but yeah but they still get blamed so
i it's again it's another one of these
things where i don't
know what to do yeah
what we're going to do about cops
because
even rooting out the white supremacists
is not going to be easy
because the whole thing is a little
white supremacy they're not even a
little it's the whole thing is what's
30 of it is white supremacy so
okay i have a question okay okay what
about this do you think it would solve
it if now this could be
total junk science but there weren't
enough cops is my point at santa monica
but
even the 40 they were misassigned and
there weren't enough of them
what if you to be a cop
at a pre at a certain location you had
to live within
that's what people always say because at
least you have a little bit more
accountability you might know
somebody who knows somebody yeah that's
one of the big things
i could be a cop in venice
still don't leave my house dude like i
just don't i'm just
stay home like i don't know neighbor i
don't know anybody right
um so it doesn't it might be
better i mean speaking about being in
the 70s like what's up baby
yeah hold on let me breakdance a little
bit with y'all youngbloods like
that's not the cops aren't going to do
that no but i think there is some
accountability when it's
your neighborhood i guess
i mean yeah i guess i don't know i i
don't i think that
um the i remember having this argument
with somebody
years ago and they were like they should
all have a college
education and make 100 a year and i was
like
they don't cops no one you get a college
education
and suddenly the desire to become a cop
evaporates you put on the [ __ ] when
you toss
the thing up that's i'm never going to
be a cop
that's what that means never going to be
a policeman
um that's that's so the funny thing is
my friend
that i went to college with uh went to
college
and there was a there was a criminal
justice degree
right she's caught for lapd she was my
uh
she was my neighbor so it does happen
it's just i'm not saying it
again i'm not saying but no you're never
if you made that a requirement
the thing is they give they give so many
bonuses out to cops who have a degree
that's the weird thing what like if you
shoot somebody and you have a
degree if you get more money simply oh
you want to be a cop
and you have a degree it's like in the
military's office or
candidate school what uh they have a
thing called ocs which is like
if you're smart you don't go to basic
training you go to ocs
a little different and like no we got
you well you can language training yeah
um
or you go to west point or whatever um
but
i the cop story is gonna be interesting
for the next i'm gonna say five years um
and then oh so biden
signed today that he's they're going to
allow transgender people into the
military
um which
if i'm biden i gotta be thinking
hey left wing you better [ __ ] give me
credit for this
for real because it's a direct yeah like
this is a big one and
uh i'm risk i mean it's basically what
liberals did
and when we were talking about why or
why are black people
um loyal to democrats it's like
because of the civil rights movement
because they wanted black people to have
rights and have paid a
significant price for it still 50 years
later
they're 60 at this point um
so there will be a
that's one of those things where no one
can run on like they let
chicks with dicks into the military they
can't but
it's quietly one of them like you see
what they do
but now it's becoming even on the right
to you know it's a veteran it's
right the veteran that's what i'm saying
they're not going to say it out loud
they're just going to
sure i serve one of them
it's just a it's it's a thing that
but they'll give them three days i want
to know i want to ask someone who's
trans that
i don't know why you'd want to go into
the military
i feel like it's it doesn't seem like uh
friendly environment it doesn't seem
friendly to me in a lot of ways
so well yeah i mean yeah
that's there's so many things like that
where you're like why would you wanna
yeah i don't i don't well i mean there's
a good reason
why would black people want to join a
all-white country club
yeah it's true it was always like why
would you wanna they don't
and like they don't want you there so
why would you
wanna but that's how life progresses
yeah no for sure i remember i watched a
thing on vietnam and how
the um there was these asian veterans
saying
it was really awkward because
they would say you know derogatory terms
like gooks
anything that was like anti vietnamese
but um they just kind of felt really
uncomfortable with it because it was so
open and they were the enemy and then
they also looked like the enemy even
though they were americans yeah
so i don't know why do people do these
things
yeah but that's i wonder did they say
would they say it
who would say what would the asian
american
military people use i don't drink no it
didn't seem like it but it seemed
so colin plays around gentlemen
let's kill the viet cong gentlemen
um the good boys over there from
north vietnam um
i'm so old i spelt vietnam in two words
i was there for like 12 hours and i
saw a really grotesque street thing what
did you say i saw like a baby with some
sort of
water on the brain not a baby but like a
four-year-old with like an
enlarged head and i my friend i was like
don't look at that
it was so important i'm not laughing
about the baby but the fact that you
said i
saw a grotesque street thing
i did it was just on the street and it
was tough
um and i have to live with it for the
rest of my life and the quiet of the
night
um dock watch well
duck watch great beautiful
could have gone longer but i i get what
you're saying um
night stalker so good and scary very
good
very scary good interviews good
footage uh what year was it in the 80s
yeah it was in the 80s 84 84 85
they kept showing places i'm like oh
that's where i park at the comedy store
yeah i'm like i bet he went to the
comedy store yeah
um now the question is
was richard ramirez hotter than ted
bundy
that's that's a weird question i don't
know have you met me
okay he's frightening looking he is not
hot
one of them he's hot most of them he's
when
let's fight what's neil attracted to in
serial killers
ready um
one of the worst things we ever did to
this podcast was adding this monitor
i mean that neither of us can see but
daniel bought it and i wanted to put it
to use and
meanwhile there's just another giant
bigger one behind this
anyhow um good looking
i literally think like would you date
that guy fright
he's mad but if he was mad at a guy cute
um uh
no not bad um
he has some enviable cheekbones the
first
yeah that's the thing he's all
cheekbones the first
mug shot of him was good looking that's
pretty good looking
like i know a lot of times i don't
understand ted bundy
is not attractive at all i think white
girls think he's good like i think he's
white girl cute
um cute yeah again if he's in the
strokes that was
that's pretty good if you're in the
strokes you're there
the sunglasses i didn't like the
sunglasses
felt like after a band's first album is
successful
and they get a stylist that's how it
felt like when he went to trial and he
was wearing sunglasses in the courtroom
like don't
[ __ ] wear sunglasses in the courtroom
well why do you mind not
[ __ ] speeding through these we'll
just keeps hitting
the next thing without going like and no
one indicates that we're done
but he's speeding through it yeah uh
sunglasses i didn't love it felt like i
said it felt like uh
the guns n roses use your illusion album
where i i prefer the appetite for
destruction where none of them
had money and they were all living with
three different women
um now scroll up well
great great yeah scary scary
scary middle kind of cute imagine seeing
him at night he would be
well the really scary one was the
library guy describing him where he's
like he smelled like a goat
ugh yeah that was or the when he would
take the children
that was just sickening well the thing
with them is uh
did not discriminate i'll say this for
richmond i gotta do it all
race not a not an object
gender anyone can get it at any time
anytime
he would not rape men i guess that was
his only yeah they had to be
like he'd molest boys no boy he's fine
the [ __ ] out of a boy and a girl no he's
it's obviously a power thing
yeah that's good sicko yeah and liked he
liked
they said he liked surprise also the
creepy part was hearing his interviews
because he they
i believed him 100 where he's like
i don't even i don't give a [ __ ] about
this [ __ ] i'm on some other [ __ ]
yeah i was like blee so you know the
funny thing
he stayed at the cecil hotel
which is re named as stay on main
which is where the asian girl
who ended up in the water tank was that
asian girl
her name was eileen something caesar
demille
sorry cecil hotel murder or this was a
this was a um this is your version of
name dropping
where it's a bunch of true crime [ __ ]
yes so basically this lady her name is
eileen she's
asian so she no no no whether it be
black dog yeah
again anyway so this if this was like in
the 2013 2014
um she was staying it's on 7th
and like los angeles and
she uh or maine obviously anyway there
we go
elisa lamp so she is acting
weird in this hotel and they have her on
video hiding
in the elevator like hiding from
something
right she disappears they find her
people start complaining about the taste
of the water and the shower and stuff
they go into the water tank
it takes 10 men to even open the water
tank she's in there with all of her
belongings
there's no way for her to have gotten in
there on her own no one knows what
happened that's her
so apparently someone after
richard ramirez stayed there back then
it was like a gross hotel for
anybody and um
they were saying okay now you're not
gonna like this part
it's haunted well here's the thing
about my ayahuasca about being a spirit
padre
yeah as a spirit of padre i
believe in don't change it hauntings a
little bit
don't change it for a second
you believe in hauntings a little bit
yeah yeah that she's
hiding yeah from something well i don't
know if that's
i uh i don't she seems frightened who
knows what there could be mental health
but
there's no way for her to get in the
water tank
that was cemented down and people in the
hotel were complaining that the water
tasted like duck sauce
wow neil i used to write for comedy guys
before there was a pandemic
anyway so richard murray stayed there
and and then a guy a journalist
wanted to go and stay in the room where
he stayed in and that guy said
he started getting urges to kill people
so i don't know this is all nonsense but
i'm just telling you
yeah i yeah
peop i've seen people
seen some things guys what have you seen
as a spirit padre
off here
[Music]
but that's the thing about being a
spirit padre is you're open
it's a different it's a different world
i don't
again astrology will never it will never
enter
despair padres world but just i'm open
um there's a spy documentary on netflix
that's not bad whether it's just a lot
of like gadgets and stuff
cool it's kind of interesting spy craft
i think
it's like not a good name yeah it's fine
uh it's
you don't need to i watch that uh french
one
uh and i forget the name immediately
every time
like what's it about pelim or some [ __ ]
what's it about
um oh belle is it bellem no
something don't look it up whatever you
do well
no french netflix uh cr uh
heist lupa
um uh it's good
well it's like cheesy good it's it's uh
it's like a tnt show yeah better it's
like the highest
it's the best ever tnt show yeah like
they got the louvre
they're [ __ ] they shot at the louvre so
right there it was really easy to watch
it's like super easy it's the kind
in terms of level of difficulty between
scenes they do
they do like right there they do
they do uh whooshes here's the thing
though he would never be with that girl
the white one the white one the boss of
um you
the funny thing is french couples
because like
they're it's all the man is always
gross and then the woman's smoking
and yeah he's i just think it was
distracting like there's no way yeah
so okay so lupa have you watched
bridgeton
that's between no haven't i somebody
told me the plot though
um and uh good for everybody
um let's do some emails well huh
do you mind babe honey
[ __ ] jesus christ
hey guys insert privileged white male
preamble here
long story short my marriage is starting
to dry up and after
talking with my wife she is not into sex
being a spontaneous thing
this is kind of a foreign concept to me
so i obviously had to start over
thinking
as to how to approach it remember how
you two talked about how neal prefers to
schedule sex
i was wondering if you two had any tips
for finding a good system
do you use google calendar do you send a
request for approval
should you get notarized and if so would
that be a threesome
well that's a that's where that
swinging a mess not a great what use it
get an actual
get an actual announcer um from an
actual baseball game
that's not bad let's do it again
should you get it no nope should you get
it notarized
and if so would that be considered a
threesome
swing in a miss you were a quarter beat
behind
we're gonna try it again don't play the
second one
ever
should you don't get it off your
computer should you get it notarized and
if so
would that be considered a threesome
swing in a miss
beautiful i teach as well as podcasts
i learned a lot how neal feel what does
the banks thinks
scheduling sex i'm still a fan
uh you just how often does your wife
want to have it
is it twice a week is it three times a
week is it four times a week
um and then you just when are you guys
available for sex
and then then you're doing it and
that's what being in a equitable
relationship is about
and i think it's the future
especially if it's coming from her if
it's coming from god of course
it's coming from a guy it's a crime
against humanity and women are going to
call 9-1-1
but if a woman wants to schedule sex
then
everything is admissible and
you make it happen it's you don't have
and yeah put it in your google calendar
google
google um put in your google calendar
yeah what's going on um yeah i think if
she
if he's not it doesn't matter even who's
asking if one wants and the other's open
do it the [ __ ] you don't nobody owes
anything
anybody an explanation for how you have
your
consensual relationship
uh consensual agreed he's asking once
they both consented
what's the best system i don't think you
like
well i guess you don't you would never
do it you would never do
scheduled sex i don't love
i don't love scheduled sex but i
uh i guess i'll say it i like having sex
enough that i don't think i need to
schedule it
no i just say there's no
need but that's fine if i let's just say
there was a time where it was needed
someone was really [ __ ] busy
someone's just so busy
i think it's like the gym where if you
you're
you're like i got ah and then you go and
you're like this is
i'm so glad i came again
again that's it i'm hanging fruit uh i
know i was just like your face was
anybody um what if isn't that
what you know it's corny but date night
i feel like that implies let's have fun
and then [ __ ]
yeah so i think the date nights are
largely
to make a woman feel valuable though
that he's not phoning it in that he's
making an effort yeah
it's never like i cater to him tonight
no you don't
who said that it's supposed to be well
it's
for women i'm saying it's like
valentine's day it ain't for him
it's like it's date night's not for him
date night it's like think it could be
for him it's not for him
you're not watching his movie you're not
watching
and women are way cooler than you give
credit like a chiller about like
if guys wants goodbye
i guess i've only have my limited
experience of dating
you've got mail spirit padre and madre
met a girl over the last month good
vibes hanging out a couple times a week
though still in that area of not knowing
if this is going to potential long-term
relationship or something that's just
fun uh question we both want to get out
of town
to some sun and have talked about going
to hawaii for a week
together soon knowing that this is still
pretty
new and there's definitely a potential
for an awkward few days if things go
sour
should i say [ __ ] it and just go for it
and we both get covered
that's i added that part um i feel like
worst case is we have fun meaningless
sex
and then maybe we don't talk to each
other again after if we decide it's not
a long-term fit
plus it's hard to not have a good time
in hawaii right
uh is it too early and too risky to
travel with someone you don't know well
advice or experience with this topic
i don't think it's a good idea
interesting
even though i've done it
[Laughter]
not during a pandemic but i just i don't
know
i don't know i don't know about it i
i think it's uh i've done it
i've done it i brought a lady on a
group trip oh did you know yeah
didn't know her well why would you do
that because i thought she would and she
mostly did hand it it was just a
it was it was about the negative thing
it was beef
it was mild beef but it's one of those
things where like the girl's
drunk and it was like she was
my date was a little
uh off but
like was she bombing it's too
complicated story
okay um but some of her
jokes no it was just it was too
complicated story and then a drunk girl
got upset and whatever um oh god
but i it was it would have been good i i
think it's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] get out of the way you want
to go on a trip hey lady it's
it's 70 30 basically it's just early 70
30 which is
you want to go on a trip i'm going on 70
30. this guy's not paying for everything
oh i thought he would oh he doesn't
mention that but i just thought he would
but even if he doesn't good for good for
her i just mean it's not seven
i'm just saying i thought it's not 70
30. uh
you know what i just i think in
covid people are getting there's a
little
tinge of desperation that no one wants
to admit
and maybe if things start going awry
i'm desperate for that vaccine i know
that it might butterball of like
oh you don't like that oh well you don't
like
i don't know i just i feel like this
we're not in [ __ ] at times
if they both are like ah who knows he
didn't mention covet so maybe he lives
on an earth where there's not encoded
oh he just meant it might be awkward he
just meant it might be awkward
to be on a trip with somebody that you
realize you don't get along with i would
say
roll the dice because you're better off
figuring it out
early i actually was talking to somebody
about this the other day and that there
should be
a version of um
the amazing race where it's all people
that have only gone on two dates
that's really funny yeah and you see
you see you see if it if it's
if it's a thing is this actual anything
cool if not you're in hawaii
and you probably had sex twice
which is more than you would have had if
you
went to y to try to meet a lady what are
things open in hawaii will
okay so yeah they can do yeah but i'm
not
even activities i'm just saying you real
you get there
you you're there for six days day three
you just realize like man there's
nothing we didn't we don't got it
it's a little awkward though yeah but is
it worth the awkwardness
i say you roll the dice goodbye
fair i say god bless son roll the dice
i'm gonna read the next one you've got
me yeah i have one for you to read
read that read this one as well
[Music]
this topic is a bit outdated but it's
gotten me into a few heated
conversations
hi neezy beezy l-o-t-r-b-a-n-a-n
here's a question that my girlfriend
threw me hate for me i think was had for
me
if covet is disproportionately more
fatal to black and brown communities
a recent study says it's two times as
deadly
wouldn't it be a stronger sign of
support to
not march for blm if one truly cares
about
negatively affecting black lives
disproportionately yours
blank i'm assuming they're black or
brown
well disproportionately means no because
he was but he was
fatal no i thought he meant because
he mentioned his proportion i don't know
i don't know i don't know what he meant
i just thought he's it's not unpopular
like uh i don't know well there were a
lot of
they there were there was no there's no
from when i remember there was no surge
from blm marches because everybody was
at least when i
marched everyone had a mask on yeah
almost everybody had a masculine and
you're right there's no surges reported
yeah because i remember i remember going
i mean i made fun of it here where it's
like that's cool is that kova doesn't
get
people seeking social justice at all sec
um so uh i
get what you're trying to do but
uh science but it the science is not
borne out
and they're outdoor they're outdoor
events
they're not even in airplane hangars
they're on the streets and also they
haven't happened in six months
um because the cops have really
come around to the needs of the black
community
goodbye you've got a man like a first
time long time thanks so much for
everything you do i was working
and living in vietnam in two words
he'd capitalized the ana nom when you
dropped episode one and in thailand for
a couple years after that
and have recently moved back to the us
been a loyal listener throughout
we've only been here we haven't been on
two years yet
for months i've been meaning to write in
about traveling southeast asia stuff
like that but after this past year and
its events i find myself having to ask
something
more pressing um i want to comment on
both of you agreeing several times since
the capitol riots
that the argument of black protesters
rioters being handled
differently in the same scenario so
obvious it's not worth discussing well
i'm here to tell you
as a lefty living in a right-wing area
of the country
currently sharing a house with the
right-wing family members my in-laws
that the race argument still isn't
obvious to a lot of white people or at
least
they won't admit that it's obvious like
many my wife and i spent the summer
arguing
with our roommates about our support of
the blm protest
being lectured about other rioters and
bad actors and being chastised for using
the old kaepernick neil
as an answer to why don't they take
better approach if they've been
protesting and writing for decades and
still haven't
aren't happy with progress this is a
long [ __ ] letter okay
um this guy's saying so my question
there we go uh are things this obvious
still worth discussing
i'm not saying they're not worth
discussing in public what i'm saying is
i don't think anyone listens to this
podcast
uh who's on the fence about it
um and
the thing if they're comparing the
capital rights to the blm riots um
the there would be the there were no
black leaders advocating for
marches riots you got to be strong
tough trial by combat they didn't have a
rally at the beginning
like i who spoke like tyler perry
uh like no obama didn't speak that's the
difference
is heads the head of state and
a hundred and some odd congress and
senate members all said that these
people had
a great point and people go aoc
aoc is a [ __ ] house member who's one
out of 438
38 and the only reason she gets
attention
is cause she's [ __ ] hot it's not
cause she's smarter than anybody it's
she's not even the most left person
right she's just
very left and incredibly good looking
for
the hottest member of congress hottest
maybe amer maybe hottest elected
official in american history
i'm gonna go on so good looking she's so
good-looking and eight
first thing in the morning nine and a
half after one of her award-winning
tutorials
so um
if you need arguments uh use the
the heads of state thing use the calls
of violence thing even though it's coded
because trump is smart enough to not say
uh he did throw in a you got to be
peaceful then why are they
why are you sending them up there and
i'll be there with you you're a [ __ ]
you're
gonna go anywhere he's like don't touch
me and then he watched it with
it was reported near near glee um
so that's the difference is organization
and uh you know peaceful
protests that you know if there's a if
there were a thousand people to black
lives matter march
maybe 20 of them were
would end up punching a whatever like
that
and they did it on their own it wasn't
they didn't get a call no one said i'm
doing this
because obama wants me to there was none
of that
and they're with the with the capital
the
insurrection there's so much
premeditation in terms of violence yes
they would save the texting and the
parlor and the we're gonna do this we
all planned even in blm movements there
was planning there was like hey
this organization's doing planning to do
this
at this time at this place yeah so it's
not like they were
if they said 130 you knew it was a black
march should be more like 220.
you [ __ ] that's fine i'll do
i'll give you a
i'll give you a duck sauce joke and then
i'll give you a better more
sophisticated racial joke
and that's how i've made got a house
okay and but if you look at on all of
all of the all of the communication
about
time and everything none of it
encouraged violence
not one and no one brought weapons no
one brought [ __ ]
thingies no one brought knuckles no one
brought tasers
no one brought agent orange
the the the scale is so [ __ ]
different and guess what
[Music]
how did police die in
what is it apparently one cop got killed
during a rob a looting situation
so you can't say no cops died okay um
cop uh that's the one you can say
less cops died uh pawn shop alarm
during a looting well you can say less
cops
died a he was a retired cop
so i don't think he had a uniform on and
uh and he got killed during a loading
situation
more they didn't know they didn't see
the cop uniform
they worked for me you work you're this
is our house
more cops died less cops died during the
protest where they were yelling
all cops are bad and
everybody was pretty anti-cop in that
yeah
protest and let's see it's just based on
their word
yes yeah so there's this yeah it's just
it's a lie it's a lie of scale that's
the
the big thing is there are similarities
in it like there was a group of people
who did a and there were two groups of
people and they both did
bad things but the reason they have
murder
and third degree murder is because
murders are not created equal right and
in this case
insurrections are not created equal um
burning a police station down which
again 10 to 20 people tops
in minneapolis that wasn't coordinated
in any way
versus storming
the capitol building of the country
looking for
um politicians to
murder kidnap hang
they had a whole bunch of plants they're
just
scale yeah just one is a one is a
one is a poke in the chest and one is a
a gunshot wound to the chest goodbye
so that's the that's the difference is
this the one you want me to read
yes you've got mayo again
[Music]
thanks has any man other than your
father maybe
ever treated you better than neil
here's my count so far rescued your ass
from europe
uh first class points flight home got
you
into the twain event failing new york
time shirts
blake griffin nike card merged leftover
nike commercial clothes
hoodies etc sprite commercial teacher
salary for two days of work
genuine friendship working together on a
podcast where it's mutually beneficial
but he is kind of a headliner name
and still allegedly gives you all the ad
revenue from the reads
there are probably many more pros we
don't know about maybe some cons here
and there but
that's for another time right now we are
guessing neil
up so just curious has any guy ever been
as kind and genuine to you in
no to you in life as neil or
is this kind of this kind white man as
good
as it has ever been i'm not sure what's
going on there also
neil are you planning some real are you
playing some real long long
long game and we are an inning three of
nine
game and where you just did the new york
times
fall in love game laying down some more
groundwork
building a good solid foundation if so i
see you dog
okay lots of digestion
a lot to unpack if this was a long game
i would it would i would be the biggest
symp
i did a podcast with her and then
i we were friends first and then i and
then i did an episode where
we fall in love damn i'm not worthy of
anyone's respect i mean
it puts a lot out there and it's a
pretty convincing argument
well i will say neil
is neil you have been
a very good friend to me you know the
thing about neil is
when you're with neil every night's date
night okay
um so swing in a mess
[Music]
again i realized that we now we need a
home run
call okay because i'll take the swings
and miss it
oh god hit a [ __ ] homer okay give it
to me
okay so yes no you're i
based on
and i said this and when we've done the
questions and it's always a theme you're
very generous
when no one's looking and you get no
credit like when you will get no credit
put money in people's pockets than when
they don't know i'm they're looking the
other way and i'll
do the opposite of the opposite of a
loop
yeah opposite of lupine it's real it's a
real necklace
um i
and even stories that i know of how
generous you've been to other friends
it's so incredibly touching and you're
you don't
play that part up at all it's just i
think it's really corny for you to just
be like
i'm a nice guy i mean i am but
you are but you don't really you don't
want to talk about it so no uh
in terms of just being a generous
supportive friend
i know but it you have and it's really
good like
you know i don't want to bring it up but
there's like one story i always think
about that i'm like
neil is that it wasn't didn't involve me
but
you're very good friend so yay
let the record show everybody uh your
honor
i'd like to bring up media goodbye
for the court and then they play that
you've got daniel and the ladies sphinx
banks and minx
at the roller rink i'm curious
who you all think got the best looking
people
banks is from like 17 different places
and you both travel the world a bit
and are very open-minded what country
place or type of person
do you think has the absolute best
looking and most appealing
mate for your taste good thanks for your
time
i can tell you it was the worst but i
once yeah i don't
i mean i could go i know i don't know if
i talked about it i found the women of
china better looking than i thought
and i think the woman the women of japan
worse looking because they all
their teeth is a nightmare it's just a
nightmare
and british you never
uh at british they've kind of turned the
they're
in the corner they've kind of rounded
the corner um
but yeah the i mean what the japanese
are doing it's the opposite of what they
did for electronics where
it's it's they're doing no innovation
yeah there's no innovation they won't
even use the exist they won't even use
like 1800s technology
right for and yellow and just like yo
do everyone do better shut up neil
so that's the japanese for you
uh i'm not gonna tell you who i think is
the least attractive
okay because i think it's a little mean
but
most attractive you know the portuguese
they are so goddamn good i don't know
any portuguese
oh i haven't dealt with any because
they're all a mix of
portuguese much like beautiful african
nations
brazil
and it's there well i don't know about
all these people
but they're good-looking they're really
good-looking i mean they're they're
they're
women are up my alley oh yeah you would
like all the women
when i went there everyone was
good-looking
uh yeah they kind of all look like that
but like maybe less hot like
that and a little less odd yeah um
they're all
like there's more sevens it feels like
yeah it's like the averages
a lot of sevens i'm not saying they're
the most stunning people in the world
but the average
i mean i remember the bus driver was so
hot
there was me and my friend walked by a
homeless man he looked like a model
everyone was very attractive yeah
yeah um where have i been where are the
looking women it's pronounced
iran i don't really
the guys in iran are good looking but
they're really cheesy looking
yeah butterfly everyone's in the 70s 60s
butterfly colors
slicked hair whose styles worse
armenians i'm sorry iranians in l.a or
iranians in tehran
iranians in l.a for sure it's worse yeah
in tehran there's like
there's like some kind of foreign style
that's a little cool
it's tight jackets it's dated but it's
kind of
interesting um i'm gonna go
women i'd go with thailand
just cause i feel like
yeah i don't know it just seems like
they're the best
of the of the asians in person
filipinos i didn't really meet any
filipino women when i was there i didn't
really mean any thai women either but
just look what you saw yeah gawking out
of my head you're hungry
uber with your hungry hazelnuts um
my uber that costs an amount that i
don't understand
in rupaul's 109
burpees or something you got okay 109
burpees
oh cool yeah uh i'm trying to think yeah
spain
didn't notice like an uptick uh what
about australia
haven't been but i i get the feeling i
would
really like the women i like australian
women's personalities
funny thing apparently australian women
not as hot when you go there just more
is that based on delia's
joke no no but then when i heard dalia's
i was like
i think this might be true because
another friend of mine is
i feel like we get exported really hot
australian women mm-hmm yeah well
they're ones who are too hot for us
right
literally i can't the opportunities for
a hot person are not enough i need to go
to the big leagues of hotness
um yeah have you been to
germany didn't notice because it was
winter
uk don't i mean didn't seem
especially crazy mexico france
french women are good-looking italian
women italian women you want to talk
about like
average of a seven hot yeah and they're
wearing they they got their own moped
yeah they
but everything's leather in a scarf it's
kind of yeah that's
fine i get that it's all tnt sergio
valencia
uh johnny barbados yeah like they
i just like it i like that they're like
no i'm leaving
oh yeah right and giant sunglasses
giants
they all have giant sunglasses i like
them
and i like their complexion italian
woman would be such a pain in the ass
for you
yeah but we make up
today we have a calendaring he says we
have
a sex goodbye you've got mail hey gang
uh lsdn er neil made a throwaway comment
on the last episode
that all the man-made [ __ ] on earth
weighs more than earth itself
paraphrasing a little this struck me as
implausible if not
impossible so i looked it up there was a
study in nature
which reported that in 2020 human-made
materials
reach 1.1 trillion tons
which exceeds the mass of all living
things on the planet bacteria plants and
animals combined
not the mass of the planet itself which
is 5.97
sextillion tons uh cue that they did a
study sound bite
they did a study a little late
especially because you can see it on the
script
just an active listener and then he left
his memo because
people are trying to get make active
listener
more than feeler trying to keep you
honest oh you know what i forgot to
add to active listener you need to say
i'm an active listener ma
which is what i use saying the joke oh
my yeah um
uh i'm an active listener mine starts
sounding vietnamese it's
ah um
uh love you all and please be nicer to
will he's trying his best
it's sometimes guys that when someone's
best
fall short what do you do dear neil
um no one yes sir even
the fact that there's 1.1 trillion tons
of our garbage is
disgusting and makes you want to vomit
this is my problem i have
okay i've lived in a few countries so a
lot of countries
burn their [ __ ] which helps in terms of
germany in the 40s go ahead
oh wow everybody you and he's the u.n
he's the u.n of insults yeah yeah the
jews can get it
they've had enough uh will neil neil
will
like you well um so
burning your trash better for the like
land waste not good for
global warming no of course not so i'm
just saying we just need i'm just like
what do we do i
i mean again you're talking to guys had
a compost for two weeks some
big careful that can get real nasty
oh i i if if i'm doing it right i'll
suck my own dick there's no way i'm
doing it right i'll
have take my own ribs out eat them and
then suck my
deck there's no way i'm doing it right
there's no [ __ ] way okay
i have the right combo it's it's gross
it isn't gross i just no it gets gross
yeah
yeah um so
something do better buy less [ __ ]
except for corona but do you think it's
better to do
shirts oh uh ben and jerry's
mansion jerry's manscaped
tuft needle designer shoe warehouse
um i could go on and on maybe zillow
we'll see come on zillow uh
so what's the lesser of two evils
burning it
or landing it
i don't know i don't somebody's done the
math i don't know
i don't know what's better can someone
tell us um
somebody hopefully somebody will goodbye
i'm going on the next question
you've got a question from neil talking
with your friends recently
talking with friends recently about
eddie murphy's raw and delirious and how
killer of a performer eddie is
and the subject came up about joke
writers my friend thought eddie had used
them but i'm not so sure
i feel like he melds his impressions
improv and stand up so well
and his jokes depend on delivery not as
punchliney as they would be
in from joke writers of the time
wondering did he use writers or is it
all eddie
any insight from what i know
he did not use writers cool and
i once asked him if he would go to the
comic strip and bomb
and he said oh no n word there was no
bombing
to me and i wish i could makes you want
to say the n word in public
when you when someone says that
something like that to you
goodbye yeah it does i'm not going to
pretend it doesn't you've got mayonnaise
hey guys you were comparing antifa to q
anon types you start in the capital
antiva stage months of riots
in portland took over a section of
seattle where people died
there are definitely thousands of these
people a lot more than 80.
no they're not uh they don't have
leaders in a very loose organization by
design so the media doesn't report on
them
how do you know that to your point about
q and on not living in reality antifa
are definitely not living around
reality they are fueled by by marxist
visions of utopia critical race theory
white privilege anarchism i would argue
they are as crazy as the qnon types the
left are not the good guys you know both
sides have conspiracy bubbles
again scale they the left doesn't
no one's in it my aunt is not in [ __ ]
antifa
your aunt is in q anon sir or you're cut
somebody you know was in queueing on
i've never met anyone who's in antifa
yeah i've been to portland i was in
portland two months ago
it was a [ __ ] ghost town there was no
camp set up there was it was cleaner
than i've ever seen portland
it might have been seasonal it might
have been but that but again
sir there are huge differences and they
are
differences of scale and at least q anon
i can point to multiple websites
and multiple channels on the chans
and uh whereas antifa is
more like 80. god bless you
i was on someone sent me the subreddit
and it's about people who
has a family member or a significant
other that's cute on
and how to and it's all like it's not
taking the piss it's how to be
supportive and support them through
realizing that through your hardship
seriously
and everything is like be supportive say
you understand
it's all these ways like antifa
like you're supposed to do with antifa
and it
you could have taken out q anon and put
in
alzheimer's and it was the same amount
of uh
support group yeah it's like they're
just confused
they don't know really what's going on
right now take them to the bathroom
in case they need to go to the bathroom
it's like nobody's doing that for
anybody else of course again it's a scam
dishonesty of scale are there people in
antifa yeah are there many of them
[ __ ] no so the idea that there's
tons of these people there's never been
an antifa march
there there was basically a queuing on
march in dc
yeah there's like they were they in
charlottesville yeah the
80 of them were in charlottesville but
it's a
dishonesty of scale steve
he gave you he gave you a he then said
big fan neil you were the best part of
the comedy store doc your point about
there not being a building that has
influenced culture more than the store
brilliant
i agree wish i had been a little more
cheery about it
goodbye but that's i'm giving myself
notes you've got me guys
le is religion basically an older more
accepted form of conspiracy belief
been reading a lot about how the uh how
to spot conspiracy beliefs
uh and noticed that most of it applies
to religion as well
uh yes it does and uh
again unlike uh antifa
and q anon marxism's a real
ideology that people are allowed to
believe in or not a lot there
that you can believe that um
that uh justice roberts is part of a
pedophile
uh cabal but it's just not true whereas
marxism is a
actual belief system
um so uh as is all the other
[ __ ] they believe um so uh
yeah it's it's religion it's um
it's uh it's uh astrology it's it's any
it's cult it's just all the things it's
all the documentary things
goodbye you've got hey neil and bianca
rstnle
sitting on the side of the road in a
sketchy part of town on my way from the
beginning of my last week of tms which
is of course transcranial magnetic
stimulation
which is a depression treatment which i
inquired with my psychiatrist about
largely because of you
genuinely touches me um i am a nurse
and work with highly complex
technology-dependent children
mainly children who live on ventilators
i thought it was [ __ ] that are
addicting to their family
and their nintendo switches you little
brats turns out it's a [ __ ]
ventilator
uh the reason i'd pull over is because
my eyes started leaking when i heard you
describe the dip in the road being paved
over after taking ayahuasca
the leaking of my eyes became full on
flooding when i heard you say
you never thought you'd need
antidepressants again i had to stop the
podcast pull over and write the letter
i don't know if that's successful or not
you got to keep the podcast playing miss
come on trying to be swift and
describing my journey with anxiety and
depression
um she did tms married
children uh when you came off zoloft was
that under the direction of your
psychiatrist
um was your psychiatrist supportive in
your ayahuasca journey
i didn't mention it to my psychiatrist
candidly
and um so
there there you go um i
titrated off of zoloft myself because
i've done it before
and i know how to do it effectively and
i know
how my body is you know how my body is
um anyway she's afraid that
people aren't going to support her in
ayahuasca including her husband
who she thinks would benefit from it and
uh her therapist so
um so yeah i mean
it's it's when i've even described it to
people
i sound corny you sound like a [ __ ]
goofball
a goof and i'm around people who who
don't really care so i can imagine
instead of sounding corny and a goofball
like no i swear
it it could be uh
seen as what the [ __ ] like you're gonna
do drugs
in a circle you know i can it's probably
gonna sound really weird
to people but i don't know man the
benefits outweigh
the looks the looks the naysayers and
it's just such a personal journey that
when you're done
you won't give a [ __ ] because you'll be
oh yeah you won't give a [ __ ]
uh i guess it's just getting her to that
place which is
would you okay if you were her would you
tell them the funny thing is
i found this out after i did it
a my sister had a nanny
who was my mom and sister and their kids
loved
and the last day the nanny i guess
because my nephews are
grown the nanny was like by the way
i do ayahuasca and my mom and sister
were like what the [ __ ]
like she said it unsolicited she's like
i go to a church they drink a tea
that's why i'm so great and my mom's
never gonna take it but
um but they were like oh great example
yeah they were like oh well that you
know they just
but if she got there and in her
interview said i do no yeah she's not
getting the job no
she's like a ayahuasca mary poppins no
it's cute
uh that's so funny uh mary
ayahuasca that's not
would you tell people if you were her
and you're like yeah shaky would you
i would tell the therapist before i told
my husband i mean
i don't want to come in
impediment meaning but there are
articles
about it just got approved the way
shrooms got approved like a decade ago
it's basically shrooms but just
on a different time it's behind shrooms
but what if her therapist is
not into any alternative uh then go to a
different therapist
until you find one that does what i want
them to do okay
um yeah i mean yeah i don't
just give that give the therapist the
articles
i just feel like a lot of people just
work and something tells me this works
yeah the thing about ayahuasca is uh
you feel called to do it yeah um
that everyone mentions like you feel
called to do like and you were
you were told to give it a rest buy
ayahuasca herself
she said give it a round yeah you're
good and you were like wow
can you define while yeah i go back i
just
clarification what are we doing um no so
when i was actually doing it i mean you
knew i was
i was asking lots of in-depth questions
uh had a premonition i was gonna stand
up and scream in everyone's face and it
wasn't that far off
but i
it felt like i was gonna do it whether i
liked it or not
like it almost felt like the moment i
was like okay i'll do ayahuasca
and i you were supposed to do it one
weekend
and i was down and i went to the desert
i went to the mojave
for camping and black people love
camping
go ahead with all of her looted tents
she once said i went with all black
people um
and i saw the tags on it
okay i went uh sorry you distracted me
god damn it uh
i went i was secretly relieved
because i signed up i said you know i'm
going to do it and because i technically
couldn't
the next time i talked to you so it goes
to how is it like oh no we're doing it
next week instead i'm like
yeah okay and that is the reason why
i felt like [ __ ] it because i tried to
get out of it once and i was really
happy i
couldn't do it so i think you're right
it does kind of talk to you in a way
yeah i don't i mean that was just
chris's fx schedule
but why we moved weekends i know but
then
i was i really but i'm with yeah they
like yeah there will be
i don't know when i'm doing it again but
but i know i'm doing it again
if well if i knew when i did it that i
was going to do it
a lot yeah you did i just knew
immediately if
this lady feels like i think she just do
it i think she should too and
don't you're not going to get results in
the same
timeline as me you're not you know i i
buddy mine did dmt the other day is
like not [ __ ] up behind it but
but it's like like he has ptsd and it's
like
it's a it's a doubt we are delicate
ecosystems
and you can't do you can't get it done
on a schedule
mine took i would say the from the first
time because i only done it once
a month a month and a half for
everything to
to fully realize all the benefits so
yeah i mean that's a whole other issue
it's there's that
and then there's um you might not get
much from the first time you might it
might take five it might take ten
whatever it's impossible to know um
until you
sit down with spirit puncher and have a
session goodbye
um you've got hello
brain trust my best friend started
dating a woman at the outset of the
pandemic color me skeptical when i
discovered that she was the mother of a
six-year-old infant
and the baby daddy had died a couple
months prior from a heroin overdose
she does not have a history of drug use
as far as i can tell after a couple of
months she straight up ghosted him
not a word after weeks of attempts from
him trying to figure out what happened
fast forward several months and she out
of nowhere sent him a merry christmas
text
with no explanation of what happened i
told him not to reply and block the
number from his phone
nobody who treats you like that is worth
your time now couple weeks later
i found out that he is actually talking
about signing a lease
and having her live with him uh just as
friends oh my gosh
my friend is a successful professional
with a good college education
but had an extremely traumatic
upbringing and i suspect
this girl fulfills a lot of emotional
wants he has left from
unresolved aspects of the trauma
basically seems like
at best he's walking right into a
codependent landmine should i talk to
him
talk him out of it or keep my mouth shut
if so how to approach the conversation
what did the bixinator ruminator and
nardo panzardo
that's so funny um
i don't think there's much you can say
old friend
yeah it's bad it's bad um too bad
for you to meddle almost
yeah there's what do you that you can't
you can't say anything you just have to
just let him know he's not getting the
deposit back from on the lease
whatever happens and that
you're just you kind of just gotta take
it
just don't hang out with them i don't
hang out with the two of them
and also you might want to have a maybe
do you do the thing of like i don't want
to talk about her because i don't think
she's good for you
yeah or give it one last hey
i just want you to know that someone did
reach out to you and say this is a bad
idea
i love those talks but it's like you
can't say
no one can say something so just a real
solid one i'm your friend do what you
want
you know you only got one life to live
but
that's not uh this is not good i don't
i i would i've never had one of those
talks with somebody
i have
but not nothing to this degree well
that's what narna pinsardo
dear bianca and neil std rpg
what nope std rpg
thank you thank you i caught the covet
even though i've been following the
stasi lake lockdown rules here in london
i was out of out on my government man
did a daily walk two days ago at
on regents canal and i walked past jimmy
carr
uh neither of us were wearing masks
jimmy
so you can let him know he might want to
get himself checked out
i like that we're the contact tracer um
uh also uh the same thing happened with
idris elba
further down the same canal four days
before this i gotta get to this canal
uh so if you know we just please give
him the heads up
um before the pandy i also saw rihanna
she looked incredible in real life even
though she seemed super drunk that was
her
on the same day i saw alexander
skarsgard he looked great
i think he might be paparazzi this guy
and ellie golden
ellie goulding she didn't uh anyhow what
are some celebrities you meant that look
better or worse in real life this guy's
a meanie i like it
i didn't say anything yeah i know you
you're good i don't play that yeah
like if if there were japanese people
i'd go out
um i got you know i protect my
celebrities
um who's
is the model chrissy turlington yeah you
like her
the best looking person i've ever seen
in person um
bradley cooper is very good-looking
interesting even at dave's thing
uh uh brody's thing which is you know
sad but
yeah he looked good interesting
um
chris paul he's hot chris paul is good
looking
chris paul's looking forward to he's
taller than you think he's like
which in life is bigger than everybody
pretty much
and he's got very light eyes this is
like light brown he's
so hot yeah i he like he made me nervous
interesting like [ __ ] get away yeah he's
cute he took me 100 bucks he was great
he's in good shape even though he looks
and
may have a gut he does not have a gut i
don't know
neil um who else is good yeah we'll
let's just talk about the good ones who
else is good looking
guy wise give a guy who do you think's
good looking as a guy
uh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] um
everything's good looking i i know i
have a name i know you do and you've
like said it well dicaprio is one of
those things where you see him and
he just looks so much like himself that
you can't even tell
no not him maybe he's good-looking um
what about who do i know they're
heartthrobs
yeah brad pitt's great looking but
that's like but at least he looks
good in looks great and he's taller than
you think
god and uh
yeah he came when i met him he was with
two black women i was like this [ __ ]
guy
[ __ ] damn it brad he walks the walk
none of this is produced 12 years of
slave
he he started i don't know i don't know
what that meant to hang out with you
um uh brad pitt's great looking
alexander skarsgard
i thought i saw him and i thought he was
really short
and then i googled it and he's not so i
don't know oh you know who i
saw liev
short very short not that that matters
but
it matters not to me i'm 5'2
so he was but hasn't stopped most other
women that are 5-2
like women you got to be tall that's
just one of the things
i i've dated guys five nine five eight
yeah that's still pretty tall it's like
it is not
above average it's average it's exactly
he seemed short to me
well once you wore him down yeah
attitude um no
oh wait but you know it's almost like
these leading guys
you think we think they're so tall i
want them all to be so tall so when
they're short doesn't mean he's not good
looking but
i'm thinking of athletes who was short
athletes
danilo galinari is the basketball player
from andy's italian he was better
looking in person than i would have
thought
but he was just i'm just remembering
like at a party
seeing that guy it's like he was just
better looking than i would have thought
okay you know who was better looking i
me and
um uh punky we were
leaving the comedy store one time and we
saw the money
the money team um we were head to
crazy girls uh-huh and she was like
[ __ ] let's go follow the point made
with i'm like
okay [ __ ] it so we go and we pull over
and we change out of all of our
we change out of all of our stuff it was
so funny
and we go to a strip club and we just
like
we were like bad spies we were just
staring at him and he was like girls
[ __ ] popping on a handstand and we were
just staring at him and he
he's not that bad looking no just
handsome
he's like more handsome he's more like
scary and a loud mouth and a rich
[ __ ] but he's not bad but we don't
talk about he's not that bad looking
um cute honestly yeah i'm i'm
i feel like i'm drawing a blank yeah and
i'm sorry for it all right well
uh the thing i'll say about most
actresses that are famous
is they all have great skin and [ __ ]
14 pound giant heads yeah what's up with
that
it's good for camera um
that's it and that's the end of
our podcast that that actresses have
giant 14 pounders
and um we
are done okay
okay
[Music]
you tell bye
[Music]
[Music]
um